hey guys justin here with a gamespot
news update the pokemon company has
announced that sales are pokemon x and y
have exceeded 12 million copies
worldwide Nintendo has not adjusted
their overall sales figures but that
likely makes x and y combined the
best-selling 3ds game so far will x and
y catch up to their pokemon predecessors
though DS titles pokemon diamond and
pearl notched up 17 point six million
lifetime sales whereas pokemon black and
white came in at just 15.4 million and
for the record the best-selling original
DS title overall was New Super Mario
Brothers which is sold 30-point 38
million copies as of the end of March
2013 all-in-all 245 million Pokemon
games have been sold worldwide even if
there were only 150 Pokemon per game and
we know that there were many many more
added in the games later generations
that would mean there are over 36
billion individual Pokemon out in the
wild for all your latest Pokemon news
and to learn how to be a Pokemon master
be sure to stay tuned to gamespot com